un año de una guerra que ha sido
calificada como un punto de inflexión
para el mundo zonas civiles devastadas
señalamientos de crímenes de guerra la
peor crisis de refugiados desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y un mundo en
vilo por las consecuencias del conflicto
[Música]
el 24 de febrero de 2022 Putin lanzó su
llamada operación militar especial con
el pretexto explícito de desmilitarizar
y desgasificar a Ucrania los intentos de
las tropas rusas por tomar Keep la
capital O harky la segunda ciudad más
poblada fracasaron pero Moscú logró
inicialmente unir las zonas del este de
Ucrania que controla desde 2014 con un
corredor terrestre hasta la Península de
crimea anexada también en ese año y
anunció además la anexión de partes de
cuatro regiones de Ucrania a partir de
la segunda mitad de 2022 los ucranianos
contraatacaron recuperaron territorio y
liberaron el imán en el este y gerson en
el sur
en el primer aniversario del conflicto
el mundo se pregunta qué tanto se
prolongará la guerra aún Hay posibilidad
de negociar Es real el riesgo de un
enfrentamiento Rusia otan y el uso de
armas nucleares está sobre la mesa de la
mano de expertos abordamos estos
escenarios que vienen en términos
militares en los próximos meses
actualmente la batalla es encarnizada en
el este de acuerdo a la inteligencia
ucranianado la orden de tomar toda la
región del donbas que engloba las
provincias de luganski y donest Para
marzo todos esperan una nueva ofensiva a
gran escala que según el secretario
general de la otan Rusia ya inició de
acuerdo a The New York Times Ucrania se
prepara para nuevos ataques en el norte
en los que Rusia buscaría retomar su
ofensiva contra la región de hark desde
la ciudad de summie Ucrania por su parte
no quiere ceder territorio y Libra una
feroz batalla en lugares del este como
bacmut y bouledar donde los muertos de
cada bando se cuentan por millares el
presidente ha prometido la liberación de
los territorios ocupados e incluso
recuperar crimeo en los próximos meses
Ucrania podría expandirse en gersón y
Buscar retomar ciudades estratégicas del
sur como melitopol esto en aras de
cortar el corredor terrestre que los
rusos controlan desde el donbas hasta
crimea mientras el alto mando ruso
seguramente seguirá enviando una oleada
tras otra para avanzar en el este Qué
papel jugará la comunidad internacional
el presidente ucraniano
a sus aliados por más apoyo militar
Reino Unido enviará tanques Challenger 2
Estados Unidos sus M1 abrams y tras una
fuerte presión Alemania prometió sus
tanques leopardos tras miles de millones
de dólares y euros en apoyo el nuevo
armamento que envió occidente puede
seguir marcando el curso de la guerra ya
lo han hecho armas como los misiles
antitanque en una primera fase y misiles
como los heimers después Ucrania ahora
quiere y pide aviones de combate la
pregunta es hasta qué punto está el
occidente dispuesto a involucrarse para
algunos expertos Europa continuará
financiando indefinidamente la guerra en
aras de protegerse de Rusia Polonia
Eslovaquia República Checa Rumanía
Bulgaria letonia Estonia lituania o sea
este grupo Son son los incondicionales
obviamente Los Grandes como Francia como
como Alemania Pues están bajo presión
también muy importante de la opinión
Pública para otros la ayuda que Europa
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido suministren
depende solamente de lo que convenga a
Washington no estamos defendiendo a
Ucrania si nos intereses de Estados
Unidos en Europa Oriental y por tanto en
Ucrania eso sentando las bases y hasta
dónde pueden armar hasta donde se quiera
comprometer la Unión Europea para
defender los intereses de Estados Unidos
y en parte ya los suyos ya dado que
energéticamente dependemos de Estados
Unidos ya tenemos que obedecerle
mientras más armas fluyen hacia aquí
alega que la otan ya no esconde estar
directamente involucrado en la guerra en
cuanto al apoyo a Rusia las posiciones
van desde el respaldo abierto con armas
como drones de Irán a la ambigüedad
estratégica de potencias como china que
no condena la invasión pero que tampoco
ha dado ayuda a Rusia Hay posibilidades
de una negociación en los próximos meses
según el exministro de defensa de
Ucrania tras capturar todo el don vaso
Rusia anunciaría el final de su
operación militar especial y llamaría a
negociaciones por eso se va a acrecentar
cada vez más todo lo que es la
conflictividad en la zona llegando
incluso a Bueno pues establecerse una
especie como de mesa de acuerdo en
virtud de lo que cada una de las dos
partes de aquí al mes de marzo o abril
pues haya conseguido otros descartan de
lleno esta vía a pesar de que Rusia por
ejemplo de vez en cuando recientemente
han mencionado que está dispuesta a
negociar siempre y cuando este Ucrania
reconozca la pérdida
los territorios declarados como
territorios rusos por la parte rusa que
es luna y gerson Que obviamente los
ucranianos Nunca van a hacerlo el
secretario general de la otan ya la
califica como una guerra de desgaste que
podría prolongarse por largo tiempo la
probabilidad de que se alargue que
quizás incluso a unos años es muy alta
para Vladimir Putin la guerra se ha
convertido en una misión casi que
personal y en una muestra de su
resistencia al dominio de occidente Y es
que Rusia es un país conocido por haber
combatido hasta las últimas
consecuencias en el pasado con altísimos
costos humanos para su población podría
escalar la guerra a un conflicto Rusia
otan en teoría Rusia no atacaría los
países de la otan siempre y cuando estos
no envíen soldados a combatir o no
faciliten sus bases para atacar a
frentes rusos pero
Moscú ha advertido que enviar más
armamento ofensivo como tanques casas y
misiles a Ucrania tendría consecuencias
imprevisibles
EEUU tiene 4.800 cabezas nucleares Rusia
tiene casi 5.000 cabezas nucleares no
importa el número a partir de las 50
casas nucleares el mundo desaparecería
tal y como lo contamos hasta dónde pues
hasta donde nieguen las negociaciones de
los grandes potencias que son china
Estados Unidos y Rusia la Unión Europea
no cuenta para nada la mayoría de los
expertos ven lejana esta eventualidad
Pues un enfrentamiento Rusia pondría en
Jaque al mundo entero mientras el resto
del planeta enfrenta las consecuencias
de los altos precios de la energía la
guerra pone en riesgo el suministro de
alimentos para millones de personas y ha
aumentado la inflación global ambas
partes ven La Victoria como esencial
para su supervivencia pero solo el
tiempo dirá Cuál de los dos Rusia o
Ucrania flaqueará primero en este pulso
si le sirvió el video para dimensionar
los distintos escenarios que plantea la
guerra en Ucrania los esperamos en otro
episodio del 5 minutos en France 24 y
France 24.com